Student Chainsaw Riot asks what does it mean to be pythonic?
Wow, Chainsaw Riot. Okay.
So, pythonic is a word that sort of describes the way you would do things in python,
if you were an expert python programmer
and we have mostly not tried to do things in the most pythonic way in this class
because I want to keep the subset of python we use as small as possible.
So many of things we’ve done, there are very clever ways to do them in python,
which would take advantage of features we don’t see.
One that comes to mind was a student posted a solution to the Sudoko problem.
That was a fantastic one line solution
that used a few things we hadn’t covered in the class
but if you want to see the pythonic way to solve problems,
I would encourage you definitely to take Peter Norvig’s class, which is CS262.
He is really a master at using python in a very clever way
and finding a way that solves problems that you would think would require
hundreds of lines of code and then both by mostly clever thinking
and clever ways of solving it but also using features of python in the best possible way
finds a way to solve it in two or three lines
and so if you’re getting more experienced as a programmer,
you are going to be finding these very elegant short solutions
that take advantage of more features in the language than we have used in CS101.